-Last time we saw each other,
if you can believe this...
-The world was ending.
-...March 12, 2020.
-Yes, sir.
-What do you remember?
-Everything.
-I know, I kind of remember it,
too, I think.
-It was bizarre.
I remember getting here
for sound check
because we were performing.
-So you were already here.
-I was here, in New York,
and I remember that
between sound check
and when we actually filmed,
there was apparently
supposed to be an audience
and then no audience.
-Yes.
-Yeah, and it was like
Rockefeller Center
was shutting down,
New York City was shutting down.
It was terrifying.
-Yeah, we were the only people
in the building.
I think it was us
and the "Today" show, I think.
-I think so.
-Like, Savannah and Hoda
just stayed over.
They're like, "All right, yeah,
don't leave the building."
-Hunker down.
-We didn't know
what was going down.
And we were supposed
to have an audience.
All our jokes are written
for an audience, and just no.
-And then, I performed
for an empty theater.
It was truly bizarre.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
No, no, it's okay.
The world --
[ Laughter ]
There was bigger fish to fry,
but it was -- I'll never, ever
forget that experience.
-Yeah, I'm always here for you,
just so you know.
I was always here.
I watched you.
I was like,
"Hey, if you need me."
-I felt the love.
-Okay, good.
-Yeah.
-But a lot has happened
since then.
I'm so happy to see you.
You look great.
-Thank you.
-But since we last talked,
since you were here,
you had a little baby boy.
-I did.
-Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, thank you.
-1 year old?
-Yeah, he's 14 months.
-Mandy's got a cute name,
and he's such a cute baby.
I want to show a picture,
if you don't mind.
-Yeah, of course.
That's Gus.
-This is Gus.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Look at this baby boy!
Come on, that's cute.
-My little man.
-Oh, he's so cute.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-He's pretty little.
Is he into anything right now,
or is he too little?
-He's walking and talking
and doing all the things, yeah.
-Oh, he is?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-"Mama" was his first word.
-I was gonna ask,
"Was it 'mama'?"
It was.
-I won!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I won.
-The first time
that you were a guest on here,
I think, was six years ago.
It was just when "This Is Us"
was premiering.
-Yes.
-And now, the series finale
is two weeks away.
It's kind of interesting, right?
-Bizarre, yeah.
-It's bizarre,
but I'm happy to see --
That's what I kind of love
about doing the show
is that you get to see
everyone's career
and start and things.
And you get big.
-Yeah, an entire chapter.
-Entire -- I mean --
-A really seminal chapter
for me, but, yeah.
-Next two episodes
are coming up.
Obviously no spoilers,
but on the emotional scale,
1 being not that emotional
10 being "This Is Us"...
-Yeah.
Jack dying.
-Yes.
Milo's character dying.
-I would say --
I will tell you that
the penultimate episode,
which airs in like a week,
I threw up after I read it.
-Ooh!
-And maybe that's just because
it's really close
to the bone for me.
Like, this has been my life
for the last six years.
And it's like I simultaneously
have to say goodbye
to the character,
to my family and friends on set,
and this character's also,
coincidentally,
saying goodbye, as well.
So there was a lot
wrapped up in it.
But I still think that, like,
you might need a day off
from work.
-Really?
It's one of those gems?
-But the finale
is a bit more of a hug.
I think there's a little bit
more levity.
Yeah, the second-to-last is --
it destroyed me.
I have a feeling it might
destroy people, too.
-Well, I know
that your show is --
it's so well-written
and so --
It's very, like, tricky
and beautifully done.
-Yes.
-And there's parts of
the next two episodes
that were filmed
three years ago.
-Yes.
And I didn't even remember.
So, the finale,
the very last episode
of the show,
just because of the way
we tell the story
and jump around in time
and obviously, like,
children keep growing
and getting older,
we wanted to capture a very
particular time in their lives.
And so, some of the finale
was filmed three years ago.
And I didn't even remember.
Dan Fogleman, our creator,
was showing us a couple
of those scenes, and I'm like,
"Wow, I don't even --"
We weren't even halfway--
-He knew it in his head
and had written it, yes.
-Had written it.
-And just saved it for
the last episode, yeah.
-He's brilliant.
Did you take anything
from the set when you left?
-I did.
-You can tell people now, right?
-Milo and I went
and did one last lap
through the Pearson house
and took some of
the family photos off the wall
and just put the frames back up.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, they were gonna
throw these pictures away,
anyway.
But they meant something to us.
I took the Steelers jersey
from the Super Bowl episode.
I took my wedding ring.
My character's wedding ring.
Yeah, I'm --
like, the sentimental things
were something
I wanted to take with me.
-Those photos must be
interesting because you probably
took them before you even
really knew each other.
-Knew each other, yeah.
There's, like, all these, like,
fake photos of me laughing
with Milo, and we just
had met each other.
We're supposed to be
husband and wife.
-I think -- I don't know
if you knew this,
but when you first
get into this show,
did you realize you were gonna
play yourself -- your character
as a teenager
and as an 80-year-old woman?
-No. So, when your originally --
you audition and you're cast
for, like, the pilot,
the first episode
of a televisions show before it
ever gets picked up
and sees the light of day,
the character
was just written in this --
You know, I'm in the hospital,
giving birth to triplets,
and that's kind of
all you see of me.
I had no idea the scale
and the breadth
of what this matriarch
was gonna be.
So it wasn't until about
two weeks
before we started shooting
the second episode
that I got an e-mail saying,
"So, we want to see
if it works for you to play
this character present-day."
And remember my mind just sort
of exploding like, "Wait.
So, I'm gonna be working with
Sterling K. Brown
and Justin Har--
And I'm playing their mother.
I'm eight years younger
than them in real life.
It was a terrifying prospect.
-But what an acting --
what a gift.
-The greatest gift of all.
-You got to stretch.
And you nailed it, bud.
Everything, I'm like,
"Oh, that was so well done,"
and you really nailed it.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Really awesome.
Awesome job.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Mandy Moore in the final
season of "This Is Us."
Take a look.
-Miguel?
[ Groans ]
Miguel?
Miguel?!
-Ms. Pearson, it's okay.
-Who are you?
-You're okay.
-Where's Miguel?
-It's okay.
-I want Miguel.
I need Miguel!
-Hey, Mom, you're okay.
-Why won't this woman tell me
where Miguel is?
Where is Miguel?
-He's not here right now.
-Where is he?
-I got it.
Thank you.
Oh, Mom.
Gonna get you back in bed, Mom.
-Thank you.
-Where is Miguel?
♪♪
-Yeah, Mandy Moore, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're talking more with Mandy
after the break.
Stick around. Come on back.
We're talking records.